you
war game red dragon is the latest title
in the spectacular RTS series you have
over 1300 combat units available in red
dragon the design and behavior of which
have been faithfully reproduced from
real vehicles reconnaissance is your
main weapon it allows you to assess the
composition and capabilities of the
opposing army to help you plan your
tactics all the unit types will be
useful in your battle strategy the
artillery can maintain offensive
pressure at long range while your
conventional forces and at rate enemy
defenses use air attacks to mount
lightning attacks on the enemy strategic
points but watch out for the
anti-aircraft defense because your
airborne units are fragile and expensive
remember to establish supply lines to
what good is a tank without shells or
fuel the infantry also plays a special
role in modern warfare and can be
rapidly deployed from transport vehicles
and places where it will be most
effective urban areas and forests
potential death traps for heavily
armored units in red dragon the conflict
shifts to Asia where you must exploit
the specific terrain and features of the
various battlefields use high positions
to surprise convoys and hollows in the
terrain to conduct Steel's maneuvers
conceal your forces in wooded areas to
lunch ambushes smoke screens are also an
excellent way of camouflaging your
troops waterways gain additional
importance with the introduction of
combat ships landing craft and
amphibious units that can move equally
well on land and sea
these mechanisms will be crucial in
every battle not only in the new dynamic
campaign but also a multiplayer mode
during incredibly intense conflicts
involving up to 20 players
simultaneously